connectivity is key for home baker asha
bitanga Jumba the entrepreneur in
Uganda's capital Kampala sells her
products online since she started baking
cakes two years ago the Internet has
been hard shells if I could get referral
client 100% clients came from social
media I would wake up each and every day
the first thing I would do is get my
laptop load em beans I would tether
using my phone get the messages I get
the feedback I do - what's up
so basically maybe the savanna running
going what's up and Facebook 3 out of 10
new garnon's use the internet and most
of them are on social media the
government now wants a new tax on their
online activities their proposal by
Uganda's President Yoweri Museveni seeks
to collect over 100 million u.s. dollars
in revenues annually all the services we
tax are critical water they say what is
life but there is a tax on what you get
electricity is a basic utilities attacks
there so the proposal is let's get your
tax on you who is coding on what's up
all you who is calling on sky because
the government is investing in an
activity Museveni says many Uganda's use
the internet to spread gossip leading
some to suggest his taxes move a way of
limiting online talk and posts there are
critic of his government others say it's
just another way to raise the
much-needed government revenue it's
ridiculous it's it's it's uncalled for
it's not researched it's it's it's one
of those knee-jerk reactions yeah
because this government at this point in
time are looking for as many avenues to
get taxes as possible
but the problem is they are deepening
the tax base as opposed to widening the
tax base so somebody's already paying
taxes
from the airtime they buy from them when
they buy that's already taxes being paid
and so again when you want to tax them
based on the data they use I think
you're touching them on three four or
even five levels level access to the
Internet in Uganda has more than doubled
in the last five years but connectivity
remains costly Internet users like jumba
already concerned that if they are
forced to pay more tax it could further
limit access to the world wide web data
has become very very expensive very very
expensive
I remember I was using 2gb paddy it was
very very high for me I actually put up
a poster on my social media suitable for
different avenues how do we get cheaper
data cause it was very very expensive as
Uganda's so-called whatsup tax proposal
comes under closer scrutiny the
government still has a lot of work to do
to strike a balance between raising
revenues and addressing all the public's
concerns